the kobit 19 vaccination rollout
continues a lot of residents keep asking
where and how can i get the shot so
christian casadas has been digging into
the story throughout the day and he's
looked at the information
he joins us now in the studio and break
it down for us christian
that's right denise well eight news now
has you covered the first step
is to see where you fall into the
governor's vaccine playbook it's
basically the chart
that breaks the state population into
two lanes as of january 18th healthcare
workers
and seniors 70 years of age or older are
eligible
public safety and security which include
law enforcement as well
and finally frontline workers this
includes essential public transportation
education and child care all this
information is available on our website
newsnow dot com now unlv and the cashman
centers are offering the vaccines
with an appointment ccsd sent out this
notice that you have there on your
screen
stating that school district staff can
get vaccinated at unlv
or at csn in henderson basically who are
medical professionals like a nurse
first aid safety assistant or a health
office backup anyone else
will be turned away according to the
notice today educators express
frustration
about the information we were turned
away
so and apparently we had gotten some
kind of an email early in the morning or
sometimes shortly before school that
said oh
there's some kind of a mistake it was
only for certain people with the
district
so i just it was really infuriating
because there were
so many other teachers well this teacher
tells us she got the link and
fought and filled out the online request
to get vaccinated but was turned away
this morning when she went in for her
appointment we did reach out to ccsd and
the health district
about this issue but we have not been
able to get through we're also getting
information about people double
booking for their vaccines remember
there are plenty of options but you have
to book
once another important note from the cdc
they are recommending people
have two masks two layers preferably two
fabric ones
i know it's not the most comfortable but
you have to remember it's for your
health and for others